[Musique]
la renégociation de l'alena ne suscite
pas beaucoup de débats au parlement
pourtant dans le passé la relation
commerciale avec les états unis a
profondément divisé les partis fédéraux
on n'a qu'à penser à l'élection de 1988
le libre échange c'est une instrument
vital absolument vital d'expansion
économique
le progressiste conservateur brian
mulroney défendent l accord de libre
échange canado américain celui qui a
précédé la lena certains et
caricaturiste n'ont pas été tendre à son
endroit et ses adversaires politiques
l'ont fortement critiqué le libéral john
turner a même accusé brian mulroney
d'être en train de vendre le canada aux
américains monsieur moroni qui vous
propose la voie de l'intégration avec
les américains ont pu remonter encore
bien loin dans le temps pour réaliser à
quel point la relation commerciale avec
notre voisin du sud a marqué notre
histoire
en 1891 le conservateur john mcdonald
était au pouvoir
cette fois ce sont les libéraux dirigée
par wilfrid laurier qui était en faveur
de la réciprocité avec les états unis ce
qui est semblable au libre-échange dans
une publicité électorale les
conservateurs affirmaient que la
plateforme libérale allait mener le
canada à l'annexion et à la ruine on dit
lauriers avec ses projets d'union ou de
rapprochements économiques ou
commerciales
dans le fond c'est le domino c'est la
pente glissante
le danger c'est l'annexion avec les
états unis et alors chez les
conservateurs 2000 donald on se drape
dans le drapeau si mcdon on va remporter
l'élection ou elfriede lauriers à former
gouvernement quelques années plus tard
il n'avait pas abandonné son projet de
réciprocité et en a fait une promesse
lors de l'élection de 1911 à ce moment
les conservateurs étaient dirigés par
robert borden le débat à émerger de
nouveaux dans une autre publicité
électorale les conservateurs avant c'est
que les américains allaient tout dévorer
il est canadien allait rester sur leur
faim
l'accord n'a jamais vu le jour puisque
bordeaux a battu lauriers il aura fallu
attendre brian mulroney pour que lee
de libre-échange run est aujourd'hui une
des différences ont plutôt entre autres
à washington et mexico contre les partis
politiques canadiens
mais si on parvient à conclure un accord
moderniser est ce qu'il fera l'unanimité
on peut se poser la question